pegi 18 c'est des conneries acheter au
juste rêvé de faire ça à nos demandes
d'excusés on se retrouve aujourd'hui
pour un nouveau concours sur ma chaîne
alors me fait pas forcément la personne
située juste là c'est ma copine 4ème
cliquez sur un jeu d'ailleurs vous
pouvez essayer de trouver leurs marques
et normes commentaire vous souhaite
vraiment bonne chance alors qu'est ce
que je fais gagner dans ce concours
c'est sûrement ce que vous vous demandez
et honnêtement aujourd'hui je vous
propose des lots plutôt cool
à savoir une ps3 ou une xbox et 3
boîtier d'acquisition de schepper médias
mais pas n'importe lequel mais
désagréable même le tout nouveau look et
leur portable honnêtement je peux vous
dire que il est vraiment bien il est pas
encore sorti à l'heure où je vous parle
mais j'ai pu savoir ses fonctionnalités
ce qui permet fer etc et il est tout
beau dit il tient dans la main comme
l'habitat fut sorti tout seul non sans
rien ce boîtier vraiment super cool et
je peux vous en faire gagner trois
aujourd'hui
alors comment le concours est déroulé
c'est très simple alors cette fois ci il
va pas falloir mettre un commentaire
dans la description sachant qu'en plus
y'a plus numéro de page maintenant vous
avez en fait juste on clique sur le
hacker plaidé commentaire le truc un peu
chiant pour les concours du coup on a un
peu tiqué
c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui game watch
m'a contacté et c'est ce site qui vous
qui me permet de vous faire gagner par
dont deux consoles alors game watch
qu'est ce que c'est avant tout c'est le
paradis sur terre un réseau social pour
geek c'est pas super ça c'est un mec
alors pour comparer un site plutôt
connue vous pouvez dire que c'est le
facebook du geek chose que beaucoup de
gens ont voulu voir apparaître
aujourd'hui c'est apparu ça s'appelle
gamewave alors le mec qui dirige le site
est plutôt super sympa il s'appelle max
c'est lui qui va proposer de vous faire
gagner ses deux consoles donc du coup
bah je me suis dit [ __ ] si la vienne
des consonnes des affaires médias comme
ça autant de faire alors bien évidemment
déçu
inscrit dessus sous le nom de squeeze
bon voulons c'est lucas avec ce deuxième
squeeze donc vous pouvez ajouter la
batterie si je vous aime ça ferait peser
tout directeur ouest voilà tu pars tu
parles mais on sait toujours pas comment
participer au final un torrent qu'une
merde
ok déjà tu change de ton 1 et toi tu
participes passés mort barbare de moyens
de participer aux concours le premier
moyen c'est cliquer sur le lien game
watch gay dans la description alors vous
vous inscrivez qu'il fait sur site
et puis l'on ajouté un ami par la même
occasion d'ailleurs et ensuite vous a t
elle devoir répondre à un qcm avec des
questions hors du commun vraiment très
très dur pour une question un peu du
même niveau que celles que vous allez
retrouver dans le cusems ce serait par
exemple quel est cet objet 1
c'est très très dur et ensuite il y aura
un tirage au sort parmi les gens qui
auront répondu bon à 75% des questions 1
donc bon c'est à dire environ 99 9% de
ceux qui participeront le deuxième moyen
de gagner c'est en cliquant sur le lien
facebook alors ça la pauvreté léger sur
leur page facebook par hayes elle va
répondre un petit cusems il y aura aussi
un tirage au sort pour les gagnants du
pcm de facebook alors on participantes
sur la page facebook vous aurez une
chance de gagner une console ou un
intermédiaire et en participant son site
vous aurez une chance de remporter
qu'une console ou deux à nos médias donc
se dire qu'il ya un navet en média plus
à gagner sur le site par rapport à
facebook mais entre amis mais je vous
conseille c'est participer et sur les
deux comme ça vous avez toutes les
chances de gagner un truc tu as vu hélas
et perfect alors j'espère que ces petits
concours vous fera plaisir en tout cas
moi je vais pas cracher sur une neuve
qui est permis de vous faire gagner des
trucs ça sera un peu débile quand même
je te propose un concours où tu peux
faire gagner vingt mille euros à ses
abonnés ah non mais dix mille euros
c'est normal non bah non mais non non
tout le monde s'en fout mais tu te
prends pour titouan d'ailleurs
n'hésitent pas à tabou n'est pas ce
qu'un nouveau conte points et en une
semaine et demie avec cette fois 20 jeux
à gagner ce qui est vraiment pas mal
donc n'hésite pas à d'abonnés en
cliquant ici puis a aimé la vidéo un
site a bien aimé que tes chances de
gagner une console ce qui est sûrement
le cas ce qui est sûr mon stage ce week
end avec est avec mes bras tu peux aussi
dire merci dans les commentaires ça me
fera plaisir mais en tout cas je vous
souhaite bonne chance et je vous laisse
sur mes deux dernières vidéos à savoir
du temps moyen et du one piece tout le
monde outreau mais en fait go
m